[Music]
hey everyone welcome to my podcast and
the series is called High School
volunteering my name is Dr and I'll be
your host for today so without further
Ado let's dive into today's topic which
is called High School volunteering High
School volunteering the positive
transformation it brings and the
potential challenges to be aware of in
today's episode we'll take you on a
journey through the powerful benefits of
volunteering during your high school
years High School is a time of growth
self-discovery and preparing for the
future but what if we told you that
volunteering can be a game
changer from boosting college
application to fostering personal
development the the advantages are
endless so if you're a high school
student or a parent wondering why your
child should volunteer stick around
because we're about to unveil some
compelling reasons why this experience
can shape young lives for the better the
benefits of volunteer work for students
in high
school there are so many things that
demand a High School student's attention
from keeping up with school work to
sports and clubs to friends and
part-time jobs it can be hard to find
the time to put in unpaid work hours
particularly for ongoing student
volunteering positions yet the benefits
of volunteer work for students in high
school can be well worth the investment
of time here's a look at some of the
benefits of community service for
students discover new career
possibilities many high school students
have varied interests and it can be
challenging to figure out which one of
those interests could lead to a worth
while career student volunteering work
can give you hands-on experience in
various fields and professional settings
it's a pure way to explore the
possibilities that may await you later
in life for example you might work on
building homes for Habitat for Humanity
and discover that you genuinely enjoy
nonprofit work you might volunteer to
teach literacy skills to children or to
ESL students and discover that teaching
may be your calling in life from
hospitals to professional offices there
are countless types of volunteer jobs
that can give you an inside look at
various professional
Fields acquire skills that employers are
looking for high school students can
benefit from acquiring skills that are
important in the workplace such as
communication and collaboration
skills volunteer work is one of the most
effective ways to effective ways to
acquire crucial skills while valure in
high school depending on the nature of
your student volunteering position it
may teach you skills such as leadership
communication organization and project
management improve your college
applications aside from college
scholarship opportunities volunteer jobs
can help you pursue higher education in
other ways for example listing volunteer
work on your college applications May
sometimes increase your chances of
getting accepted this type of work
experience could help your application
stand out from the crowd the benefits of
volunteering for college
students college students may experience
being even more busy than they were in
high school not only are you juggling
your class schedule and homework clubs
and social activities but you're also
learning how to navigate life as an
adult it may not be easy to cram one
more obligation into your schedule
however fitting in a few hours of
volunteer work here and there can be
worth it learn invaluable soft
skills soft skills or people skills are
something you can learn while
volunteering employers may also
appreciate your ability to better
communicate take accountability take
initiative and engage in
teamwork these are the skills that are
primarily learned through practical
experiences rather than classroom
lectures acquiring these skills could
make you a more desirable job candidate
no matter what industry you choose to
specialize in some of the soft skills
you may acquire as a volunteer include
the following collaboration and teamwork
it takes many hands to see a project
through to completion this means that
volunteers must learn to work well
together and to manage the life cycle of
a
project communication volunteer work
brings together people from all walks of
life you'll practice effective
communication with your fellow
volunteers and with the people you serve
time
management volunteer work could teach
you how to manage your time more
effectively after all you'll need to
juggle those volunteer hours along with
the rest of your obligations you'll need
to make the most of the time you have
professionalism professionalism is
typically something that workers learn
through on the job experience one of the
benefits of community service for
students is that you'll have a jump
start on acquiring
[Music]
it